okay so you have not seen Tiger King
you've not seen Tiger King basically
Tiger king is a docu-series about a
bunch of insane people who like Tigers
but also don't really care that much
about the Tigers they care much more
about their own personal self
aggrandizement it features a bunch of
different characters so the main
character is a guy named Joe exotic who
is a gay polygamist who is gay with men
who are straight that he traded meth to
them allegedly in order they would have
sex with him and then he married them
and then one of them accidentally killed
himself
also he runs a tiger zoo but he also
sells Tigers to people around the
country he has a running feud with a
woman named Carol Baskin who proclaims
that she is a tiger rights activist she
also happens to probably have killed her
former husband and hates Joe exotic and
has been trying to shut down Joe exotics
distribution of tigers for years
simultaneously claiming that she is a
tiger rights activist well holding
tigers in cages that don't look all that
great in her own sort of private Zoo
where she has volunteers who work for no
pay
and then there's a third character who
sort of pops in as sort of an advisor to
Joe exotic named doc and doc has
basically a cult that he is set up of
he'll have 17 year old women in turn for
him and then he will keep them in
basically patties like in stalls until
they realize they're supposed to have
sex with him and then they have sex with
him and then he makes them part of his
harem and uses them as part of his draw
to his little zoo about three-quarters
of the way through the docu-series Joe
exotic starts being played and
manipulated by a guy named Jeff Lowe
Jeff Lowe is that person who kind of
likes Tigers but also is just
straight-up insane conman who wants to
steal drugs on exude appears pretends
that he is super duper wealthy while
taking out enormous amounts of debt and
has a bisexual wife with whom he carries
on various cavorting Zin Las Vegas and
who is basically trying to get jogs out
accosted from his own zoo and or
prosecuted so he can take over the zoo
so there are your cast of characters Joe
exotic ends up in jail
Carol Baskin ends up triumphant because
she helps put Joe exotic in jail and doc
is you know doc he continues to operate
Geoff low ends up in charge of Joe
exotic zoo Joe exotic is the tragic
Hamlet asked Shakespearean character
what a weird and crazy and insane group
of people this was so let's go through
this thing spoilers are allowed so let's
start with the obvious did Carole Baskin
kill her husband yeah she totally killed
her husband right I mean like there's no
question I have already proposed that
there is a fantastic rom-com slash
suspense film to be made in which Carole
Baskin after killing her new husband
meets OJ Simpson they meet cute and like
a resort and it's because OJ wants to
buy a tiger or something or he just
wants to adopt a tiger because she
doesn't sell Tigers and they meet cute
and then only after they get married
they realize that each one of them is
allegedly a murderer and then they have
to figure out exactly how who is going
to murder the I think there's a great
movie to be made there by I'm gonna
recommend to Jason Blum I know about you
yes she she definitely liked her husband
Raden ibly disappeared just gone poof
and he was super rich and she was a very
weird person before that he was a weird
person too but yet she did no question
no question she killed her husband right
like she didn't like zero percent as far
as other Joe exotic really incredibly
threatened Carol the evidence there
seems kind of mixed honestly because it
seems as though that Jeffro fellow was
really manipulating the entire situation
right the Hitman who was being who is
being solicited by Joe exotic was
working for the guy who was trying to
steal Joe exotic zoo if I'm getting this
correct so I think there is a real
possibility that that guy was basically
soliciting Joe exotic to say a thing on
tape that was going to be damaging to
Joe exotic but Joe exotic didn't
actually pay him to kill Carol Baskin I
think that's a possibility and now it
says everyone in this documentary
deserve to be in jail pretty much
everyone deserves to be here but did did
Joe exotic credibly threaten Carol
should should Trump pardon Joe exotic
and then make him Secretary of the
Interior there's a possibility there's a
possibility is Geoff elope an evil
mastermind yeah I mean he certainly
portrayed that way right I mean there
okay so first of all it's pretty clear
that Joe exotic is supposed to be the
hero of this particular piece and
exotic is a scumbag right in the
documentary he's basically trading meth
for sex with straight dudes which is
very very weird and creepy and
horrifying and then falling in love with
the straight dudes who are having sex
with him for math and then singing songs
and about them and and describing
graphic carnal acts at their funerals
there's so much in this thing like
there's just so much in this thing but
yes Jeff flow appears to be a con artist
right he appears to be a scam artist and
the idea that he sort of been trapped
Joe exotic is drugs addict happens to be
a pre-existing condition crazy person
yeah that's that seems to me like a
fairly good theory does that mean that
drugs addict wasn't guilty of the crime
no hey Joe got it could have been guilty
for the crime and Jeff Roe could have
been Jeff Oh Jeff Rolo could have been
trying to trap him I both could be true
but Jeff Lo is is a skeezy dude a very
very skeezy dude all righty if Tiger
King were made into a movie who would
play the main characters as a question I
have seen asked before so if you're if
you're going to cast the the tiger King
movie so there's only one obvious
casting decision so there is a a
character in here who looks like almost
exactly like Aaron Eckhart Erik Ali okay
Erik Kelly is the person no question
that this person is Aaron Eckhart then
you have who would play Joe exotic I've
seen the suggestion that maybe it should
be Edward Norton I kind of like Edward
Norton as drugs Ottomans a really good
actor so I could definitely see that I
think there's a world where you have
anything could be sort of a good a good
comic actor maybe Owen Wilson as Joe
exotic would that work man mmm
McConaughey is Joe exotic yeah so I
guess so I could see a Laura Dern Carol
Baskin maybe I should have to gain a
bunch of weight obviously who else is
Carol Baskin hmm Laura Linney is Carol
basket Laura Linney a--from from oh
sorry I've seen Stephen Merchant is
Howard Basking that that would make
sense to me
staff is apparently a transgender person
which I didn't know like if you watch
the series you don't know that staff is
a transgender person because this is
clearly a woman who had her arm bit off
but
currently this is a bit of a controversy
online I've heard that staff does not
care about that well I would imagine not
since staff literally had her arm bit
off by a tiger and then they said we can
reattach this and she was like f it I
don't need the arm so who would play
staff I've there's some people
suggesting Michelle Rodriguez which
which I think would work oh now this is
a great suggestion so Sean Finlay who is
the meth and the allegedly meth-addicted
husband who was straight of joe exotic
who spends beans hair documentary short
listen one of the great things about
this documentary is dudes shirtless the
entire time and you never ask why
because everything is just so crazy
that's like the least crazy thing about
this documentary somebody suggests Shia
LaBeouf excellent suggestion excellent
suggestion Travis Maldonado is the other
husband who kills himself let's see
could see army hammer here maybe is
maybe a little bit too old ah this is a
good suggestion as da cantle as a bag of
on back antal I'm seeing suggestions of
Jon Hamm that is good call Jon Hamm is
da cantle would would totally work if
you're alive Philip Seymour Hoffman is
doc until his dead is dead ringer I mean
like seriously easy casting have a Brad
Pitt for Jeff Lowe did you see it like
as a con man is it kind of charming con
man yeah you could teach Brad Pitt his
jeff low although it doesn't work so
well if he's like a handsome dude right
he has to be kind of not super handsome
has to be a guy who thinks he's handsome
but it's actually not supremely handsome
all right that's enough thoughts about
tiger King for anybody and far too many
for most potential later